you were so famous during that internet
era for Flickr but you meet people today
they're just like what's Flickr right
like they don't know you meet a lot of
people they just think of you as an
investor oh I don't know I've done a lot
of things in the interview I was
including you know getting involved with
Etsy and being the chairman of Etsy for
that's a biggie of that time yeah um you
know fur that was kind of an eight-year
journey journey which was a long time
pretty amazing because if you think
about Etsy that was a New York company
that was turned down by almost everybody
for investment right like that was not
popular anybody I walked it around the
valley
I took it famously to people like Reid
Hoffman he's in the heart Pass it was
and I think it was not obvious to a lot
of people why well because I mean you
know the questions that I were asked
were
oh so let me get this that's like it's a
bunch of women knitting sweaters and
selling them to each other yeah I'm like
yes yes it's a tremendous opportunity
and and I think that it was just not
obvious until the numbers started to
roll in why was that obvious to you that
was the thing it was very obvious to me
because here we were at the beginning of
what I think a lot of us sensed was a
big movement right it was a movement it
was the DIY handmade maker maker be your
own boss your own boss right it was
actually it was actually a kind of an
exhaustion with big-box retail and
Target and Walmart and all of those
companies yeah and so this was a return
to you know handmade soap yeah and
carpentry that was actually done by your
uncle in his garage and it was like a
whole movement and the entire following
decade was about that another investment
that I made during that time was Blue
Bottle coffee and Blue Bottle coffee was
at the forefront of the artisanal food
movement that's interesting because Blue
Bottle when I heard Tony Conrad invested
which was way after you I think no he
was the one who showed it to you put
together the whole angel contingent he
was on it what was that first round he
was the valuation he was not out of
money it was it was not hi
yeah it was somewhere in that range and
I actually at this point don't remember
but sold for 700 million dollars to
Nestle and the event and the thing is is
that it was also at the time an odd
thing for tech investors to invest in
food and it just it seemed at the time I
remember thinking to myself well I don't
know anything about coffee in fact as
you and I are sitting here you notice
that we both drank tea
yeah we're tea drinkers and I at the
time had never driven into the coffee
I've never lit Earl I invested in it
because I could see that it was a
extremely strong brand it had it had
James Freeman who is this coffee guru
who had been building it in literally a
garage on Hay Street yeah for 10 years
and I live near there and so I would go
down there be lines through the bluff
line and and you know I was like this is
a tremendous brand right right and you
know I had the misfortune of like an
entire wired Japan television crew
showing up in my office one day to
interview me about Blue Bottle coffee
and the very first question was so
what's so special about this coffee what
does it taste like
and I'm like mmm it's smooth it's very
smooth but I know a good brand and I
think that that I think it's also very
true that that startup had just on you
know unbeatable authenticity right it
had a coffee
obsessed founder who had been working at
it product boiling yeah
founder product fit I guess we caught
her finish yeah yeah I think that's what
it's called these days but it was you
don't find anybody as into coffee
Russ James I heard this is somebody's
home in the second-hand they used to
know how to manage the queue so that
there was a line at all time so they
took their time Oh
part of the training was actually to
have there be a little bit of
and to make it worth the wait okay so
not like scarcity but you know buzz
that's super interesting and also
possibly they had several famously the
Gibraltar which was the yeah had like
off menu items that people who were in
the know I'm true connoisseurs yes I
think that your alters like a Cortado
it's like a equal parts milk and
something foam or something like that
it's like twenty isn't it amazing we're
sitting here in 2019 and there are like
forty different coffee beverages and the
average like truck driver or person in
Middle America or in China who you know
who just came down from the farm country
they know what these forty items are to
that hard occasional trend that you
identified right right I mean and so you
know a lot of what we do with the SVC is
look for those kinds of movements we
look for things that there's the
momentum behind them you see like all of
this most successful investments that I
have made yeah Etsy Blue Bottle Cloudera
which is part of open source movement
and Kickstarter you know all of them
were part of some kind of unstoppable
movement